there's a brand new article out in
business insider that is absurd this
article is a profile a hit piece
whatever an analysis of spring health
spring health is a company that has
built a two billion dollar valuation
mental health startup by a founder who
is 29 years old this founder is a female
who has been on an absolute tear
building a 2 billion company in a very
short period of time now before we get
into what my problem is with the article
i first want to explain some of what's
in it there is a title that says april
co built a 2 billion mental health
startup by age 29 so obviously really
playing into a young person built a
really successful business but in some
of the analysis we have reporters that
are saying things like spring spring
health offers therapy and coaching as a
corporate benefit to clients including
general mills pepsico and instacart
they've built impressive financial
numbers but they also have problems
underneath so what are those problems
some of their employees say that they
experienced a pressure cooker
environment which they worked non-stop
and under close scrutiny that feeling
fueled dozens of departures to some the
always-on work first lifestyle that has
long defined startups no longer seems so
alluring or even sensible when it's
stood in direct opposition to the
prescriptions for happiness that their
startup itself is selling and many told
me
speaking about the reporter that they
were worn down malia russell uh that
they were worn down by what they
described as a hard driving growth at
all costs approached by a young chief
executive who appealed to their idolism
while her startup's mission but at times
seemed blind to their basic needs here's
my problem is that they went and they
wrote this entire article about a
technology startup and basically what
the claim is is there's a young female
founder who built a two billion dollar
company and people at the company said
that they had to work hard that's
essentially what this is think about
that for a second we have tech workers
that are complaining about working hard
they couldn't find hard work if they
were looking for it with a flashlight in
daytime what do i mean hard work is not
going to your corporate office working
on your apple laptop getting free snacks
and having somebody push you to be a
better performer over your virtual
messaging platform because you're too
scared to have a one-on-one meeting with
them where they might yell at you for
bad performance or for not being
productive that's what work is you go to
work to be productive and they pay you
to be there that's why it's called work
it's literally in the name it's work if
you don't want to work then don't go get
paid a cushy salary at your job j-o-b
it's a job my problem with this is not
even so much that the reporters are
doing something wrong look the reporters
basically go and they talk to a bunch of
employees and what they talk to the
employees they maybe they have some sort
of hit piece in mind maybe they don't
i'm not here to to try to guess what a
reporter has in mind but what i do know
is that when the tech workers are saying
oh they worked us too hard the reporter
should literally be writing an article
that says tech workers are soft because
hard work isn't going to that corporate
office and working off your apple laptop
hard work is actually being a single
mother trying to support two kids while
working three jobs that's hard work hard
work is going and doing manual labor at
a construction site for 12 hours when
you get home you're so tired that you
can't even eat hard work is literally
immigrating to this country and
30 40 years old not knowing the language
and trying to build a brand new life for
yourself those are situations where
people work hard hard work is not
playing on your computer for too long
and anyone who's trying to say oh i got
paid this really cushy salary and i
literally benefited from being there and
they worked me too hard
quit nobody's holding a gun to your head
saying that you have to work there quit
but the problem is that we've weaponized
complaining
in our society the more that people
complain the more power they get the
more that the media gives them air and
gives them momentum worked hard
literally there are millions and
millions and millions of americans who
would beg to have your job and if you're
too arrogant and stupid and privileged
to think that your hard work
at your corporate job working on your
apple laptop
isn't good for you quit and give it to
one of the millions of americans who
would be thrilled to take your place
because ultimately what we're finding is
that people don't actually understand
what hard work really is
and to say that oh i went and worked at
a company that went from nothing to two
billion dollars in valuation of course
it's gonna be hard of course you're
gonna have to work long hours of course
you're gonna have to be diligent and
productive that's why the company is
successful the best companies in the
world understand you hire great people
and they produce great work people don't
sit around at the water cooler and
complain oh we're working too hard or
complain wow i can't believe that
they're making us do this
no in fact it's the exact opposite
people show up to work every day and
they say what's the job that needs to be
done today and then they get to work and
then once they're done with that task
they ask what's the next thing that
needs to get done and they have a
unquenchable thirst for more work those
are the people that companies want to
hire because those are the same people
who go in with an owner's mindset these
employees they have equity in the
business they're part owners in a
business
but yet they still are complaining
somebody yelled at me on slack or
somebody literally made me work too hard
again you didn't work at a construction
site where you literally were doing
manual labor you're not a single mother
of
two kids working three jobs stop
complaining
nobody cares get back to work or go get
a new job and we should stop
celebratizing this stuff and stop
weaponizing the complaining of hard work
and then turning around and saying it
from what i understand from the article
nobody's accusing anybody of breaking
the law of doing anything that is
unethical or anything that would
normally be considered as bad
it's literally just people saying they
worked us too hard pretty crazy stuff
joe john what do you guys think yeah i
agree i was uh pretty frustrated with a
lot of other people when i saw the
article i think it's interesting because
you shouldn't accept a job like this and
and not be expected to to work hard or
be pushed or to feel like you're
insecure in your job and all this other
stuff right like that's literally what
you are signing up for you're signing up
for a high-paying job at a tech startup
and that's literally what comes with
that territory so tech startups are hard
right any startup is hard any building
any successful startup is hard making a
big startup is is obviously very
difficult but building a two billion
dollar show that's nearly impossible
right when you think about the odds of
that so obviously there are some things
going on there that aren't normal
workplace culture i think i think that
is uh understood by just about everyone
but i also think it should be understood
by just about everyone taking that job
that that should be expected of them and
they should understand that and i i just
think like you have other options right
if you're going to complain about it go
get another job no one is forcing you to
do that no one is forcing you to go in
there
and work extended hours or do things you
don't want to do right i think what you
need to figure out if you're in that
position is can i go get a job that that
maybe requires me to work less time
maybe you make less money but that's
your problem right like these are jobs
that you're being offered these are jobs
that you're willing for willfully
accepting and i think everyone that that
company needs to just take a step back
and say hey is this really what i want
to do because i'm sure as the ceo of
that business they would rather then
step back and say hey maybe this isn't
what i want to do then have someone
half-ass commit do a bad job and
complain to other people i'm indifferent
about this reporter actually putting out
this report right she's just reporting
on what people are telling her she does
not work at the company all that stuff
is insider is
a conversation of its own what they've
been writing recently but it is it's
that owner's mindset right when you go
in and know that what i do directly
affects how i get paid you work a little
bit differently and people saying that i
have a supervisor yes that's how
companies work is it's tears of company
tears of people and you get supervised
because they want to make sure that
you're actually producing work um and i
believe that a lot of these employees
that are complaining most likely if they
were the actual ceo of the business
they would think that them themselves
are being lazy by what they're producing
for work so i don't really see any merit
in it um like you agree to the work you
signed up for the salary if it's not
what you didn't uh if it's not what you
expected when you took the job then you
have the ability to quit that's kind of
why you have that ability you're not
trapped there um and also find something
you enjoy doing and you will never work
a day in your life right that is what
everyone's always been told and look
it's it's work if you deem it work if
you find it and you enjoy it it's not
actually work um it's more fun for you
yeah and i think the big piece here is
that there's an entire world where
people literally are starting to uh
uh
believe that this stuff is hard i i've
worked many of these jobs right i
believe john and joe both as well as me
we've worked at grocery stores we've
worked at fast food chains we've worked
at ice cream shops shout out john
hitting it with uh with cold stone like
we've worked the service industry jobs
right i was in the military i worked at
a large tech company right we understand
joe worked at a bank right john worked
at an analytics startup at a company
that was growing very quickly et cetera
and so when you look at this we've
worked in a number of these different
roles and guess what happens there's
people who enjoy it and people who don't
but if you are working in an environment
where literally your complaint is that
it's a hard charging environment
that that isn't a shot at the company
the company is being successful they're
doing what is necessary in order to get
outsized
outcomes you have to give outsized
effort it's like a sports team coming
together and saying man that coach
really worked us hard but you know what
we won the championship the champions
never complain about the work because
they want to win
if you are more concerned about
something other than winning that's fine
okay but that might not be the place for
you and again i don't think that people
are sitting there saying oh they're uh
this is i think joe you might have said
that this is like people working at uh a
warehouse or doing some sort of physical
labor or something like that you're
working in an office environment and
you're getting paid handsomely to do it
a
software engineer right now the average
salaries for these folks 150 200 250 000
in compensation a year we're not talking
about somebody's getting paid 40 000 and
being asked to live in a major metro and
they can't afford how to live there
they're not being asked to do that stuff
and so i think that again it just goes
back to we've got to call out this stuff
when we see it if you don't want to work
hard then it's not the right place for
you then okay that's fine but let's not
weaponize that stuff and instead we
should focus on the fact that people are
going to have to work hard at a
fast-paced environment like a startup
that is trying to defy the odds the odds
are that you are going to fail of course
the task is hard do the hard work or
stop [ __ ] planing